l'arrière du bus n'a pas résisté au choc
ce matin vers 8h30 ce cars scolaires
s'est renversé sur la route
départementale enneigée
le véhicule a quitté la chaussée lors
d'un dépassement à son bord 30 élèves
âgés de 11 à 14
tous les enfants étaient sortis donc à
notre arrivée donc au sauf une jeune
fille qui effectivement s'est retrouvé
dans le coin c'est donc à l'arrière du
bus ou un soudain des montants qu'il a
fallu donc dégager tout cas des moyens
de secours routier donc c'était la seule
personne qui était coincée une jeune
fille donc qui est donc blessés graves
et qui transportait donc sur le centre
hospitalier de beuvry le pronostic vital
n'est toutefois pas engagé
deux autres jeunes plus légèrement
blessés ont également été hospitalisées
de leur côté les collégiens dden ont
rapidement été évacués des lieux de
l'accident les enfants ont été pris en
charge ils sont ils ont été mis au chaud
avec un petit chocolat la salle des
vallières psychologique pour les enfants
et pour les parents parce que bonté les
deux sens a soutenu quant à l'intérieur
médecin pompier
si colog reçoivent écoutent les enfants
car quelques heures après l'accident
l'émotion et les souvenirs sont encore
bien présents elle avait passé et quand
elle a tourné balbutié
c'est
puis tournée il tombait dans
[Musique]
j'existe
j'ai vu mes copains mal un de mes
copains très blessée qui nautique a été
coincé sous bus et first jouant pour
déterminer les circonstances précises de
l'accident
une enquête a rapidement été ouverte le
chauffeur évidemment est en situation de
garde à vue et donc il est actuellement
en train d'être interrogé par la
gendarmerie pour clarifier les choses
le véhicule qui a été dépassé donc le
chauffeur le chauffeur du véhicule le
conducteur du véhicule et a entendu
comme témoin et donc nous en saurons
plus bien sûr dans les prochains dans
les prochains jours pour l'heure les
tests d'alcoolémie et de stupéfiants de
la conductrice se sont révélés négatifs
ce soir après auditions le parquet nous
indique que la vitesse et la manoeuvre
et est inadaptée sur des routes
enneigées